[INTRO MUSIC]
SHEREE HAGGAN: OK,
"The View UpStairs"
is a provocative new
musical that pulls you
inside the UpStairs Lounge,
a vibrant '70s gay bar
in the French Quarter
of New Orleans.
This forgotten
community comes to life
when a young fashion
designer from 2017
buys the abandoned space,
setting off an exhilarating
journey of seduction
and self exploration
that "Entertainment Weekly"
calls "a moving homage
to LGBT culture,
past and present."
Filled with
"beautiful love songs
performed by a soulful
ensemble cast."
So, please help me welcome to
the stage, to perform for us
now, the cast from
"The View UpStairs."
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: It's 1973,
y'all, in the Big Easy--
New Orleans.
[MUSIC - RANDY REDD AND COMPANY,
"SOME KIND OF PARADISE"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JEREMY POPE AND TAYLOR
FREY, "CRAZY NOTION"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JEREMY POPE AND
COMPANY, "THE FUTURE IS GREAT"]
[APPLAUSE]
SHEREE HAGGAN: All right,
let's give it up to them
one more time.
That was beautiful.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
View UpStairs, y'all!
SHEREE HAGGAN: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
Thank you.
And then, we have a few
members of the cast who
won't be joining us
for the Q&A. So we've
got April, James, and
Ben-- thank you, guys, so
much for performing.
That was wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
Where are you going?
[APPLAUSE]
SHEREE HAGGAN: They're
going to go explore Google.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Oh, OK.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Raid
the "microkitchens,"
that's the plan.
All right, wonderful.
Thank you, guys, so much.
RANDY REDD: The what?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
Yes, I got you.
SHEREE HAGGAN: [LAUGH] I
know that quite a few people
in the audience weren't able
to see the play just yet.
But they will be
seeing it after this.
So I would love for you guys to
introduce yourselves and tell
us a little bit about the
character that you play.
RANDY REDD: I'm Randy Redd.
I play Buddy.
Buddy is one of the older
patrons in the bar--
the bitter, old daddy.
He's also the piano player.
He was sort of a washed up
singer-songwriter who landed
in this bar in New Orleans.
ANTHONY ALFARO: I'm Anthony.
And today I was playing
Freddy, a Puerto Rican drag
queen with a heart of gold.
But I'm a swing, which is
an understudy for a bunch
of these fabulous people.
And, yeah.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
Good afternoon,
everybody here at Google.
I'm Nathan Lee
Graham, and I play
Willie in "The View UpStairs."
And Willie is the--
let's say, he's the bon
vivant of "The View UpStairs."
He's the matchmaker, the
Dolly Levi, if you will.
He likes to bring
people together,
even if he has to use
alternative facts to do so.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's who I play.
So you have to come and see him.
TAYLOR FREY: I'm Taylor Frey.
I play Patrick.
He is currently a hustler to
make ends meet and stay alive.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yass.
TAYLOR FREY: Moved
to New Orleans
to get out of his
bad home situation
when he was growing up.
JEREMY POPE: I'm Jeremy Pope.
And I'm playing
the character Wes,
who is an aspiring fashion
designer who is sent back
to New Orleans in 1973.
And yeah, that's all
I'll say about that.
[LAUGH]
NANCY TICOTIN: My
name is Nancy Ticotin.
I play two roles in the
show-- the realtor who
succeeds at selling
this doodoo-head-- no,
he buys the building
that is left.
And I also play Inez, a mother
of the drag queen at the bar.
And the husband has left them.
And she's supporting
and doing the best
she can to keep the
family together.
In reality, in the real story,
she has two sons at the bar.
But in our show she has one.
SHEREE HAGGAN:
That's incredible.
Great.
Thank you, guys, so much.
And how was it that you guys
got involved with this play,
or you found out about
it, and were cast?
Were there any fun stories in
terms of auditions or anything
like that you want to share?
RANDY REDD: I joined
this show back
in-- there was a reading
of the show in October,
a developmental, week-long
reading back in, I think,
October, right?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yeah.
RANDY REDD: And I
was not involved.
[LAUGH] But, come
Wednesday afternoon--
I teach class, and I was
in the middle of class,
and I got a phone call-- can
you come now and join the show?
Can you learn the part
and go on tomorrow?
So we did two
performances on Thursday
and Friday, readings
of the show.
So I joined the cast sort
of out of the blue, yeah.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: And thank
god he did because he's
fantastic in the show.
RANDY REDD: Thanks,
Nathan Lee Graham.
ANTHONY ALFARO: Yeah.
RANDY REDD: Can you
translate "bon vivant"?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Bon vivant?
Google it.
[LAUGHTER]
RANDY REDD: See what I--
I set you up there.
[LAUGHTER]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Oh, god.
The part of Willie
was written for me.
So that's how I became a part
of this wonderful musical that's
based upon something that
was very tragic that happened
in 1973, in New Orleans--
five years ago, almost, Max
Vernon, who wrote the book,
lyrics, and music.
So that's how I got involved
with this beautiful project.
TAYLOR FREY: Some of us
weren't involved at all
and then just auditioned,
like, as an actor,
you get a lot of
appointments to come in.
And you go in and do your best,
and you hear tons of no's.
And then, sometimes
you get a yes.
So, that was this one.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah, me too.
NANCY TICOTIN: You don't
want to say anything?
JEREMY POPE: I was the same.
I auditioned, and I hadn't
heard about the project
prior to auditioning for it.
And then when I got the
call to come in, I went in.
And I actually met Taylor,
who was already hired.
So it was kind of a cold read.
And I had to interact
on top of all that.
TAYLOR FREY: Oh, and
they didn't tell you
that I was in there, right?
JEREMY POPE: No, I
went into the room.
TAYLOR FREY: Which
is kind of messed up.
JEREMY POPE: And
then, he was there.
And they were like, so
this is the person that
is cast as the role.
So create chemistry, and go.
And so we did, and--
[LAUGHTER]
TAYLOR FREY: So, usually you
know those things in advance.
You can prep.
And they didn't tell
any of the boys.
JEREMY POPE: They didn't
tell me, which is great.
But we kissed in the room,
and the sparks were flying.
TAYLOR FREY: Fireworks.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah.
And then, it was a yes, so
feeling great about that.
[LAUGHTER]
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's wonderful.
NANCY TICOTIN: My
story's a little similar
to Randy's, in that
there was someone
else in this role prior.
And she got bumped
up into another job.
And then, they called me.
And I was thrown into this.
I was living upstate
New York in the snow.
And then, I read the script.
The next day I said yes.
I packed two bags.
The next day, I was
at rehearsal at 10:00
and didn't know
where I was going
to be that night-- sleeping
on couches for a long time.
But out of the blue,
just like that.
I didn't know that about
Randy, interesting.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Wow.
That's beautiful.
Now, you had mentioned, Nathan,
that this is a true story.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yeah.
SHEREE HAGGAN: And
can you tell me more?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Well,
it's based upon a true story.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Well--
and anyone can please jump in
and modify or correct, please--
but in 1973, there
was an arson attack
at a lounge called the
UpStairs Lounge in New Orleans.
And they're not sure
who started the fire.
But this fire did
indeed killed 32 people.
Some people got out.
But it is 1973.
This is the south.
It is New Orleans.
And so, it was under-reported,
under-investigated,
and to this day,
you can literally--
all joking aside-- Google it
and find out more about it.
But it's still an
under-reported,
under-investigated story.
And it's our first
Orlando, if you will,
for the LGBTQ community.
So it's an important
story, a pivotal story.
And what Max has done is taken
the wonderful character of Wes,
that Jeremy plays,
from the present day
and transports him back to 1973.
And we all come alive.
And all of the machinations,
and contradictions,
and differences between
1973 and the present day all
happen in this one bar
before this tragedy happens.
And so, it's a beautiful
story about something
that was tragic that
needs to be told.
And I'm just so proud
to be a part of it.
Does anyone want to add?
RANDY REDD: Yeah, as far
as under-reported goes,
I grew up just north
of New Orleans.
I was probably 10, 11, 12
years old when this happened.
And never knew of it.
Never heard about it
until this show came up.
And there's still-- I talk
to my friends and family
back home, and even
people in New Orleans who
don't know this story.
And it's just outrageous
to me that it's
gone so missing from our
history, certainly, you know.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Absolutely.
TAYLOR FREY: What's cool is that
now people are seeing the show.
And I have two people
that have contacted
me who have had trips planned
to New Orleans already,
saw the show, and went
and found the bar,
and looked and saw the
names outside of it.
There's some in the sidewalk.
There's some on the building.
And so, that's really special.
We get to kind of
honor those lives now.
It's really something rare.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
It's incredible.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Now,
it was under-reported.
And you guys mention
that quite a bit
that the news didn't cover it.
Why do you feel like
it wasn't covered
when so many lives were lost?
Before Orlando, which
you had mentioned,
this was the largest attack
on the LGBT community.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
Does anybody want to--?
ANTHONY ALFARO: Well,
I would probably
say that it was because
they were all gay.
And I think that, not only
was it under-reported,
but the families
of the victims--
I'm sure a lot of them
were quite embarrassed
or felt some sort of shame
about having their kids,
or their kin, or relatives at
this place that was kind of--
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Well,
I mean you would be fired.
ANTHONY ALFARO: Yeah.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yes.
NANCY TICOTIN: Lose your job.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: So
you would lose your job.
And then your names
would literally
be put in the paper,
sometimes with your address.
And you would lose
your job for being
even associated with these
people, let alone, at the bar.
So there was shame
on all fronts.
And the people who
were actually victims,
and the people who
were actually there,
couldn't even express
their shame or their grief
for fear of being fired or
for fear of being let go.
NANCY TICOTIN: So many bodies
were not claimed, even, right?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yeah,
many bodies were not claimed.
There were people
across the street who
watched this place burning
down, and they did nothing.
So, and they left
one particular member
burnt to a crisp
in the actual bars
that were up to the windows.
If you know New Orleans, they
had these very large windows
that you can sort
of walk out of.
They're like doors.
Well, this was on
the second level.
And so, in order for drunk
people not to fall out of them,
they ironically put bars
up to keep people safe.
And then you have a fire.
And there you have it.
So, you know, the shame
all around of being a part
or associated with the bar, and
the real-life time happenings
of not being able to tell people
because you would be fired.
Cut to present day,
where you can still
be fired if you are
gay in certain places
here, in these United States--
if I'm not mistaken.
So there you have it.
SHEREE HAGGAN: And
we reference Orlando.
And for those of
you that don't know,
in June-- which is Pride
Month-- of this past year,
there was a shooting that
happened at a nightclub there,
called Pulse.
And so, when we say "Orlando,"
or if we use the term "Pulse,"
that's what we're
referencing, which
is now the largest killing
of the LGBT community or hate
crime towards the
LGBT community.
So that's what we're
referencing there.
How did it feel, so soon after
the Pulse shootings happened--
how did it feel bringing
this story to life?
Was there an element that
felt a bit more powerful?
Do you feel like it
was the perfect time
to bring this to light
because it's so ironically
similar to what just happened?
JEREMY POPE: I think,
for me particular,
I'm from Orlando, Florida.
I live here in New York
City, but I was home
when the shooting happened.
And we lost a bunch of familiar
faces, people from high school,
all types of things.
So I didn't want to
deal with what happened.
It was very hard for
me to deal with that.
I came to New York
after, and I just
started auditioning
and trying to forget.
So I thought I was
going to be in LA.
And then this
project came along.
I read the script.
And I was like, I
need to do this.
I have to do this for me.
I need to do this because
this is so important.
I didn't know about
this New Orleans attack.
So, like Nathan has
mentioned, yes, it is tragic.
But it's such a
beautiful story, where
you get to meet so many
individuals full of life,
full of character,
such important stories.
And it's so great to
be a part of a piece
where, not only are
we creating art,
but where we're sharing history.
And I feel like
that's so important
to not forget our history,
and where we came from,
and those that came before us.
So for me in particular,
it just struck
a chord, where every
night feels like therapy,
where I go through, and I
get to meet these characters.
And, yes, it's sad.
But it feels progressive, like,
OK, we have to keep fighting.
And we have to keep speaking up.
And we need to
keep doing whatever
we need to do to keep
taking those steps forward
in the community.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
Great.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
It's so timely, too,
with what's going on in society,
as far as the administration
that we have
currently happening.
So it's a timely piece, a
seminal piece, in that way,
on all fronts.
I really feel like it's
just, we are a part
of a larger community of artists
who are putting out some really
great work right now.
And I mean artists
at large, too,
because I think even what
you guys do here contributes
in so many ways
with communication,
where communication
is concerned.
So, that's so key.
You know, I think the
operative and big word
today is "communication"--
dealing with people and
communicating with them.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
That's wonderful.
Thank you.
And we talk a lot
about community
and the importance of
community-- and community then,
as well as now.
Now, the bar-- it was
really interesting
because it served
so many purposes.
It was a church.
And it was a bar.
But it was also like
your hangout place.
And you'd do drag shows.
And I feel like every
couple of minutes
it was just changing into
morphing into something new.
What was the bar like for you?
And what did it
symbolize for you?
RANDY REDD: Well, I can only
speak from Buddy's perspective
here.
You know, Buddy is the
showman in the room.
It's his room.
It's his show.
It's his night.
And it's sort of
taken away from him.
But it is the place where
Buddy can be himself.
I didn't say that Buddy
is married and has kids.
So he's living this other
life inside the walls
of the UpStairs Lounge which,
you know, while this is not
based specifically on one
guy, it's based on reality,
for sure--
you know, this guy
hiding out in this place.
So it is a place to escape.
And it is some kind of paradise
for all of these people,
you know.
And in that, it really is
how it starts for me, too.
And the night sort
of progresses, or--
TAYLOR FREY: I think "escape"
is a good word that he used.
Because for my character,
it definitely is that.
and has become kind of a safe
haven for him to be who he is.
And, much like what New
York City was for me when
I left Utah, [LAUGH]
I kind of got
to be myself, and do my own
thing, and explore everything
I was.
And I feel like Patrick gets
to do that by just coming
into this bar every night, so.
RANDY REDD: Yeah, I remember
when I was in college--
I went to school
at Florida State--
and, you know, I grew up in
this small town in Mississippi.
And I went to college
in Tallahassee.
And the gay bar in Tallahassee
was very seedy, divey bar
downtown in the basement
of the Hilton Hotel
out by the capitol.
And it was called
Club Park Avenue.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, mirrors on the wall.
It was like black velvet.
And it was so, so seedy,
and so much like this bar.
There were drag shows
on Sunday nights.
And that was my escape.
You know, like, I really felt
then like I was in this place
now.
It's a very similar experience.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Great.
That's awesome.
NANCY TICOTIN: I
think for me, it's
a place where my son
can go and be himself,
and where it's safe.
Because, even when we enter
into the show, my character
and my son in the show--
it's after being
beat up by a cop.
So in this place
is the only place
where we can feel safe,
relax, feel good in your skin,
I think.
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's great.
Go ahead.
ANTHONY ALFARO: Well, I
was just going to say,
speaking to Inez and Freddy,
they're Puerto Rican.
So I think that, even in
their home, in their family,
with their relatives,
you know, this
would be something that would
be really kind of shameful.
And the fact that he can
go there with his mom
and kind of have
this extended family,
it's like a living room.
It's like grandma's
house or something
like that, where you know you
can go there and feel at home.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah,
that's so true.
And that's the vibe
that I got, as well.
Fun fact-- I moved here
from Utah, as well.
So we're going to
have to talk to after.
ANTHONY ALFARO: Yeah.
Wow.
SHEREE HAGGAN: It's
so much to talk about.
But we talk about it
being this safe haven
and this sense of community.
And it symbolizes
so many things now.
But then, there's
a song and it talks
about how you're going to try to
be a person, not a personality.
And I feel like any
more now, our community,
or our safe haven, is like,
we hide behind technology.
And so, we have these apps.
And we have these chat rooms.
I mean, our whole world,
our social network--
that's our social world, is
our social media or technology.
And we're a tech
space, so technology
is very important to us.
But how has that morphed
our sense of community?
And not necessarily,
it doesn't have
to be a bad thing, but how have
things changed since the '70s,
in terms of the LGBT community,
and what's safe haven,
and what that means now?
RANDY REDD: Don't
all speak at once.
[LAUGHTER]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
You want to take that?
JEREMY POPE: I'll take it.
Yeah, I mean, because my
character's from 2017.
So Wes wants to be--
he wants the following.
He wants the Instagram
following, the Twitter
following.
He feels like, in order to be
loved, he needs those things.
In order to be respected
as a fashion designer,
he needs those things.
So he jumps into
this world in 1973,
where these guys
don't have that.
They only have each
other and this safe haven
to spend time
together, and to fall
in love, and to fight,
and to argue, and to fix
all the things that are going
wrong in life, in this one
place.
So it's very interesting for
him to kind of deal with that
and see--
just kind of dealing
with that, I think.
But like you said, yeah,
we live in this world
now, where we are
living behind screens.
And that is so important.
And I've been to
auditions where they
want to know how many
followers you have.
Or that qualifies you
more for X, Y, and Z.
So it's hard to grasp
that because I don't know
if we have the communication
of face-to-face communities,
where we can go
someplace and have
real conversations with people.
Or is it all just behind
this screen of swipe
left, swipe right,
if I'm interested.
So I think Max has done a
great job of just presenting
the facts and kind of
letting you deal with however
you deal with your social life.
It's not necessarily a show
where we're preaching like,
we need to get off our phone!
You know, it's just the
reality of how things work.
And there's positivity in
that and negativity in that.
And you kind of can
stray either way.
TAYLOR FREY: I do
love Instagram.
[LAUGHTER]
I really, really do.
The problem that
I'm finding with it,
is people only put out--
I've made this a goal
in the last year.
My husband was like,
if you're going
to be on it as much as you
are, be your authentic self.
So I've made this goal to try
to be myself on Instagram,
like, no holds barred.
Just go for it.
And that's one of the issues,
is we only put out there
what we want other people to see
or what our insecurities are.
We're hiding.
We're putting them away.
And people can actually
start living in this reality
world of what they're putting
out to their followers
as themselves, and,
like, lose themselves.
It's kind of crazy.
I saw Ted Talk on this.
And the effects on
the brain of it--
you actually start to lose
yourself a little bit.
And you count on
what other people are
seeing as being the real you.
And it's insane.
Excuse me while I
post on Instagram.
[LAUGHTER]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: And
I'm one of the older
members of the cast.
And so, my relationship
with technology
is antagonistic at times
because I'm an artist.
So my whole thing is about--
it's all these contradictions.
My whole thing is about actually
dealing with real people,
you know, and making
that sort of connection--
even if it's through celluloid--
but connecting with real,
sort of, human emotion.
But at the same
time, I'm acting.
Or I'm being, right.
So there's always these
constant contradictions.
And so, you're trying to be this
"real artist," quote, unquote.
And then you have this
element of social media
that you have to deal with,
which sometimes takes you out
of your artistic self.
But it needs to gird or support
what you're doing artistically.
So there's this
constant give and take
in flux, generationally
with me, in particular--
where I'm like, can someone
else younger do this for me
while I work on the art?
[LAUGHTER]
TAYLOR FREY: Well, what's
crazy is it's so tied now.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Yes.
TAYLOR FREY: Like
it really is tied.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: It really is.
TAYLOR FREY: To promote
your show or whatever,
you have to put that out with
your name attached to it.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Absolutely.
TAYLOR FREY: So whether your
personal life is there--
I mean, it's just a lot.
And it's all together.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: It's a lot.
And it's exhausting!
[LAUGHTER]
But--
RANDY REDD: Here we are.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Here we are!
SHEREE HAGGAN: And
here we are, though.
TAYLOR FREY: At Google--
doing the live feed.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I love it.
I love it.
NANCY TICOTIN:
[INAUDIBLE] too bad.
[LAUGHTER]
SHEREE HAGGAN:
Yes, as you should.
So we're going to open it
up for audience Q&A here
in just a moment.
So if you guys do
have any questions,
feel free to line up.
We've got the microphones on
either side here for you all.
So it sounds like there's
so many life lessons.
And when I walked away, I was
like, social media cleanse.
And I had my sister
change my passwords.
So now I'm like,
off social media.
Because I'm like, I need
to be in the moment,
and I need to be person
and not a personality.
And I felt like there
were so many lessons
strewn throughout and interwoven
throughout the entire play.
What do you guys feel is the one
thing that if people walk away,
you hope they got that?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Wow,
that's a great question.
RANDY REDD: Wow.
NANCY TICOTIN: Well,
I think what gets me,
and what I love that
the audience gets,
is the political point of view
that we speak of in the show.
People relate to it.
And they find solace.
When they leave the theater,
they are moved emotionally.
They feel comforted
that it's being
addressed in an artistic way.
It's not being knocked
over your head.
You don't read it, et cetera.
It's something you
experience with us.
His character is
primary in that goal.
And we all, backstage,
eight shows a week,
as long as we're there,
we are re-experiencing
what is happening in the world
and sharing our common goals,
or our wish, that we can
all move forward and find
emotional happiness and
make progress in the world.
And I think the
audience does get that.
I feel that.
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's great.
TAYLOR FREY: I would say,
the political climate,
that's all very prevalent in
the show, and the technology
aspect, and how people,
as we were discussing,
can lose themselves.
But besides that,
I would just say--
this is going to
sound so cliche--
but there's such a message
of love in this show.
Because these
people in the South,
in 1973, had to find
themselves in a little room
together to let their
freak flag kind of fly.
And I just can't help but
finish the show every night
just thinking about
love, and acceptance,
and just being who you are, and
celebrating our differences,
instead of trying to hide
them, and hinder people
from being different.
ANTHONY ALFARO: I think this
kind of ties in everything.
But the past few
months have been
kind of trying for
me, personally, for--
like, what he said about
our administration and all
this kind of stuff that
seems so out of my hands.
And just like, oh my god,
they're going to kill me
and everyone I love, you know.
And I think that,
for me, the blessing
of being a part of this
show, with all these people,
was kind of that escape, with
like-mindedness, and love,
and kind of a celebration
of all the things
that make us different.
So I find that when I
speak to my friends who
come to see the show after,
they kind of experienced
that kind of escape.
They experienced that in
that hour and 40 minutes.
And there's usually this kind of
energized smile on their face,
or like a sense of relief
after, that things will be OK.
And I don't know, I feel
like they kind of learn along
with us.
And that's always the
kind of best thing for me.
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's great.
Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you
so much for being here.
Loved the show.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was there last week.
Going to go again this week.
RANDY REDD: Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: Sheree,
great job moderating.
My question is, so when I was
at the show, what really struck
me was your script, right--
your dialogue and all your songs
and poetry.
It was just absolutely amazing.
I was wondering, do you guys
have one favorite lyric?
Or one favorite sentence
that you're just
absolutely obsessed?
And when you read it, you
were like, oh my gosh,
it totally speaks to me.
Something that really-- your
favorite line from the show,
maybe from your character or
from your fellow characters,
as well.
NANCY TICOTIN: There's so many.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
There's so many.
TAYLOR FREY: Mine is, we've
got an iron bond no hate could
break apart, that he sings.
Obsessed with that line.
Love it.
NANCY TICOTIN: I like your line.
I told you this.
He says, well, look at me.
I'm a total failure, but
my life is not so bad.
[LAUGHTER]
I love that line.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Oh, god,
it's So hard because there's
so many wonderful lines.
JEREMY POPE: [INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
See, I'm so in it
that I've gone beyond the
actual context of the line--
content of the line.
I'm more about how
it sounds, right.
Because they're all good.
All the lines are good.
So-- because it changes
after a couple of weeks--
my current sounding line
that I love so much--
Michael Longoria is not here.
But he has a line, (SPANISH
ACCENT) where is my dress?
[LAUGHTER]
I love that right now.
It makes me laugh every night.
I'm offstage.
And I just love it.
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's amazing.
All right.
And Nancy, so that would be
your son in the play, right?
And what I have
found so interesting
was that it was
based in the '70s,
but you were so
supportive of him.
And you were so loving.
And just, you took
him as he was.
And it was beautiful.
And it was something
that I longed for.
My mom is wonderful
and very supportive.
But it was more than
just a love of him,
it was of everyone, and
everything that he was.
And that's so rare, even today.
How did it feel playing a
character where it's like,
in the '70s, when it's like,
you think of everyone hates
everyone that's different?
How was that?
NANCY TICOTIN: My
experience, personally,
is that, first of
all, I was a dancer.
I was one of the original
members of Ballet Hispanico
of New York.
And so, I lived my life with
a lot of gay guys, always.
And my parents-- it was
just part of our life.
There was no question.
One of my cousins was one
of the dancers in the show,
in the company.
And one day, he
said to me, Nancy,
I just have to tell you--
I'm gay.
And I'm like, I know.
And he was like [PANTING].
You know, like he was
so scared about it.
But with this show,
I mean she struggled.
It wasn't like, oh, you're gay.
It's fine.
No-- she went through
a lot of hassles.
And she was scared.
And she doesn't know
anything about how
to live a life with
a gay guy, her kids.
And then the husband leaves her.
And she's there.
And she's struggling on her own.
But that's the love.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
NANCY TICOTIN: And
it's a mother's love,
not just for him, but
for everybody in the bar.
You know, like, I feel like
it's kind of a universal--
I'm the "big momma," you know.
And I'm so connected to
Michael, who plays the role.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
NANCY TICOTIN: We
just have this bond.
And we have a lot
of fun with it.
But it's a challenging--
I find that the whole show--
and I'm used to doing singing,
and dancing, and acting,
and kicking my
legs, and all that.
And I don't do
that in this show.
But I find the show
very challenging
mentally, vocally, emotionally.
It takes a lot of
my concentration.
And I love that.
Because then I'm
growing, and I'm sharing.
I love to have that
challenge, yeah.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Yeah.
It sounds like this
character embodies
some of who you are, too,
like that truth in the moment.
NANCY TICOTIN: Absolutely.
And I have so many
people, after the show
that I speak to,
they're like, oh my god,
I wish my mother was like you.
You're like a dream,
fantasy mother.
I swear, they say those lines to
me, which are in the show, too.
Yeah, it's wonderful.
I love it.
SHEREE HAGGAN: That's amazing.
And it's definitely
how I felt. Afterwards,
I was like, please be
in my life forever.
[LAUGHTER]
It's so wonderful.
But I just loved it so much.
That was probably one
of my favorite parts.
NANCY TICOTIN: Thank you.
SHEREE HAGGAN:
And it's something
that I just longed for, I
guess, and that yearning.
NANCY TICOTIN: Thank you.
SHEREE HAGGAN: So my
last question for you
guys today, this is for Nathan--
what would you think is the
biggest difference in terms
of dating, 1973 to today?
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Well,
all of you kids are spoiled.
[LAUGHTER]
Nowadays you can't
walk into a bathroom
without 10 guys following
you into your stall.
[LAUGHTER]
But, once upon a time,
things were not so simple.
There was no cruising
on the bread lines.
In my early 20s, I had to
intercept more coded messages
than the allied forces.
[LAUGHTER]
But I was hungry for love.
And I certainly found it--
painters, poets,
diplomats, sailors galore.
[LAUGHTER] Even a
sword swallower.
[LAUGHTER]
They, of course, fell
deeply in love with me.
How could they not?
It is an undisputed
fact that I had
the best legs in all of
N'Orleans, for a man or woman.
[LAUGHTER]
Mr. Balanchine told
me himself when
I auditioned for the ballet
"Russe de Monte Carlo"
in 1940--
keep your mouth shut.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, mind you--
and I'm no dancer--
but he was ready to
take me on my silhouette
alone, except for that nasty
prima ballerina, Danilova.
Oh, she was a fright,
and jealous, too.
How I would have loved to
tweeze every wayward hair
of her boorish, Russian face.
[LAUGHTER]
But who would have
known where to begin?
[LAUGHTER]
That's all.
[APPLAUSE]
SHEREE HAGGAN: Thank you.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
And you can see
that monologue eight
times a week, done
in a very different way,
with lots of physicality,
at the Lynn Redgrave on
Bleecker and LaFayette.
SHEREE HAGGAN: 45 Bleecker.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM:
Tuesday through Sunday.
SHEREE HAGGAN:
Yes, it's so true.
You can also visit them
at theviewupstairs.com.
Or you can visit them on
Twitter and Instagram.
The handle is @theviewupstairs.
Thank you, guys, so
much for your time.
NATHAN LEE GRAHAM: Thank you.
SHEREE HAGGAN: Please,
let's give them
another round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]